okay let's go to our next caller let's
try the 765 area code caller from 765
introduce yourself and go right ahead
with your question
hello Dave Thomas thanks for taking my
call I enjoy your show I really enjoyed
the segment you did it on a pseudo
intellectualism
I thought that was very well done and
very in-depth and I enjoy a lot of your
programming on that first question I
have is do you have anything published
yourself you have any books or research
that you published under your University
professor no I don't anything in
development may be coming out uh you
know I've been working with a literary
agent a nonfiction literary agent for a
probably like a year and a half at this
point just coming up with possible ideas
but we haven't found anything yet that
you know the idea is a nonfiction book
that I would have a unique perspective
on right not like just another generic
progressive nonfiction political book
type of thing and we've just not found
something that is both a good fit and
that could be completed in an amount of
time where we know that it would still
be relevant that's the thing with a lot
of these books that unless you do it in
a very specific way and/or with a
ghostwriter it just takes a while to get
it done and so I'm it's something I'm
talking to a literary agent about but
nothing in the works yet Oh we'll
definitely keep us inform and I think
you got a lot of bright ideas I want to
get to my main question have you read up
on anything about this Chinese social
score that they're and plan on
implementing and yeah we've covered it a
little bit what are your personal
thoughts on that I've must've missed a
segment but if you give me like a brief
I mean it's a fact idea like a credit
score but it's like a social credit
score so it goes beyond just your sort
of financial reputation but more of a
broader reputation I don't know that
it's that useful and I think the
possible risks of it kind of outweigh
the benefit I find it incredibly
interesting because I'm really a I'm a
student of the gamification of different
areas of life so I think that the
incentives that the incentive structures
that
creates are very interesting and can
sometimes have positive effects but they
often also had out I'm sorry what was
that
I know boy you're cutting out yeah
all right listen we're losing you
I think listen Pat what is my position
please explain to me what my position is
on this if you remember it I I I think
that basically I I it's it possible
dangers I don't know how much we gain
from it although I'm interested in
gamification yeah
I'll have to catch up do the research
check out your past statements on thank
you